[Music]
when I was a little girl growing up I
never dreamed about ever being a country
singer
I guess that's just too big of a dream
for a little girl that didn't have much
didn't have hardly anything
about her humble roots is what helped
make Loretta a legend I did go to bed
hungry and I guess I just knew I was
hungry I didn't know we were poor in her
final years Loretta endured many Health
battles she suffered a major stroke in
2017 and a broken hip in 2018 but the
following year in 2019 she had recovered
enough to attend an All-Star birthday
celebration in her honor I feel great
[Music]
[Applause]
from Carrie Underwood to Dolly Reba and
pink Loretta was admired by all a
Trailblazer and considered country music
royalty she always credited her work
ethic for helping make her a star I
think I worked probably harder than
anybody in the business I've worked
harder than all of them tell you the
truth she was still making music well
after she turned 80. it told me that you
had found someone new oh I feel great
and I love to get out there and sing and
the people sing as loud as I do when
they're in there and they're from I have
people from 10 years old to 80. he
shovel coal to make a poor man's dollar
Loretta's life story was made into the
movie Coal Miner's Daughter in 1981
[ __ ] Spacek won the Best Actress Oscar
for playing Loretta even though she
wasn't that familiar with her music when
she got the role she went down and she
bought all my tapes
that at that time it was eight track
tapes and she learned all the songs and
she said that she never listened to
country music she always listened to
rock and roll Miranda Lambert and Sheryl
Crow also shot a Coal Miner's Daughter
music video with Loretta at her
Tennessee mansion
[Applause]
[Music]
when this one come along I said now they
can't talk about me because look how
country she is
hey I'll fill those shoes anytime I'll
try to she's great
the four-time Grammy winner had six
children early in her career the working
mom struggled balancing home life and
career sometimes leaving them behind
when she went on tour I've given up a
lot but I've given a lot to and people
have given a lot to me I've raised my
head and set myself
but the country girl never forgot where
she came from never wanted to stop
creating the music she loved I don't
even know what retirement means I want
to die with a pencil in my handwriting
and it hit song a honky tonk song
[Music]